as it turns out the 2009 Sports drama
The Blind Side had some blind spots some
linebacker sized ones in fact this is
how the movie missed the mark The Blind
Side gives much of the credit for
Michael Oher's rise from poverty to NFL
star to the Tui family who took him in
and helped him get into college
do you have any place to stay tonight
don't you dare lie to me but it took
many people from other parts of Orr's
life to provide the support and
opportunities he needed to achieve
athletic stardom in his book I beat the
odds from homelessness to The Blind Side
and Beyond or credits some of his 11
siblings with protecting him when he was
a child he was his mother's sixth child
he also says that even though he and his
siblings feared social workers because
they didn't want to be separated he now
appreciates that his caseworker did
their best to not let him slip through
the cracks although some of Orr's foster
homes were less than ideal as he put it
in the book some provided at least a
measure of security that said he would
still try to run away to find his mom
the movie does show that before ore met
the tuis he was staying with an athletic
coach from his public housing complex in
hurt Village Tony Henderson whose last
name is Hamilton in the movie helped or
get into a private high school in real
life it was Briarcrest Christian School
not Wingate to be fair to The Blind Side
most of the movie takes place after Orr
has entered Wingate but that Focus still
pulls attention away from the other
people in his life who did try to help
him including his own family and people
from his community Michael Orr has one
main issue with the hollywoodized
version of his life namely it's the
film's implication that he's
unintelligent rather than quote a kid
who never had consistent academic
instruction and ended up thriving once
he got it as he wrote in his Memoir in
real life Orr pointed out he was already
playing and studying football and
multiple other sports when he met and
moved in with the tuis in The Blind Side
Orr meets the tuis shortly after getting
into Wingate through a friendship with
their young son SJ it takes a
demonstration from SJ and Leanne Tui
interrupting practice with a
family-based metaphor for ore to figure
out blocking in reality by the time Orr
and the tuis connected he was already
running track and playing basketball the
sport he originally thought he'd Go Pro
at as well as football
the two parties met at various athletic
events and it was the Tui patriarch Sean
who noticed Aura was Couchsurfing
without a stable home Sean started
paying for ore's School meals and then
offered him a place to stay for one or
two days at a time Orr was invited to
Thanksgiving and finally Leanne asked
him to stay permanently
according to Orr the greatest help that
the tuis offered him didn't come in the
form of football tutorials but their
ability to take care of his most basic
needs while speaking of People magazine
in 2021 or talked heavily about the
positive impact that being taken in by
the tuis had on him specifically Orr
said that it was the stability that the
two is provided for him that allowed him
to thrive and grow into the person he's
become or told people when I started to
see that I had two or three pair of
shoes to wear to school and I had
multiple pants my mental health started
getting stronger I could focus on school
and my grades started to go up I was
eating so I could focus on other things
rather than being hungry that's when I
really started to excel to the credit of
The Blindside creative team the 2009
film does shine a spotlight on the Toy's
efforts to provide ore with more clothes
food and shelter shirt and a plastic bag
is not a wardrobe mic however the film's
decision to rewrite ore's football
education results in it turning its
focus away from the greatest ways that
his adoptive family helped him or told
people I started to create that path
because I didn't have the small things
to worry about and it all came from
Health it all came from help from other
people and other resources and without
that I wouldn't be here since or retired
from the NFL in 2017 he set up a
foundation called beat the odds
Incorporated which helps children from
underprivileged backgrounds achieve
their own dreams he also launched an app
Good Deeds which helps to connect people
with resources to those who need them
Michael Orr has never been shy about all
the ways The Blind Side exaggerated if
not outright fabricated elements of his
life his career and his relationship to
the Tui family but things took an even
more shocking turn in August 2023 when
it was revealed that or filed a lawsuit
claiming among other things that Sean
Leanne Tui never adopted him like the
movie depicted he's going to be 18 in a
few months doesn't really make much
sense to legally adopt
in the lawsuit Orr says that the tuis
instead manipulated him into giving them
power of conservatorship over him just
after he turned 18 which put them in the
position to control his business deals
because he was led to believe it would
make him a legal member of the Tui
family or then explains that they used
that power in signing the deal to make
The Blind Side all but cutting him out
of the millions and royalties that the
rest of the Tui family earned from the
hit film there are wonderful kids all
over this country in this world that
want a forever family and we believe
that there are no unwanted kids they're
just unfound families the legal filing
states that Orr only just learned in
February 2023 that he in fact had no
legal familial ties to the Orr family
despite Sean and Leanne having continued
to refer to Orr as their adopted son and
continuing to use that for their own
professional and financial gain he seeks
to end the conservatorship and to force
the tuis to disclose all of the money
they have earned by using his name and
license as well as borrowing them from
doing so in the future
[Music]
foreign